President Trump goes to the college
football national championship game Lena
Dunham breaks up with her boyfriend what
was he thinking for five years and
president Trump is called crazy by
everyone but is the 25th amendment
really a thing or not so much ben
shapiro
ben shapiro show
oh yeah so last night was apparently an
amazing national championship football
game I will admit that I did not watch
one single second of it number one
because I'm not a big college football
fan number two because I cut the cord a
while ago and I don't have any of the
alternatives to actually watch the game
but there's a lot to talk about because
of a lot of virtue signaling by some
folks on the left and president Trump
goes down and sings the national anthem
and the whole deal we'll talk about all
of it but before we get to any of that
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at bling cast okay so you
have a busy day you have a lot going on
you're in the car for maybe 15 minutes
and after you finished listening to my
show at 4 times speed you've decided and
now it's time for you to get educated
about something else what do you do you
turn to blankets blankets has these 15
minute blinks this great app they've a
15 minute what they call blinks in which
you can basically get the main points of
a book in 15 minutes or less it is
fantastic instead of you having to wade
through 500 pages of a book spend hours
at a time reading these books you can go
through four books in one car ride
you're in the car for an hour suddenly
are going through four books right it's
just fantastic and then the list of
books that they have on blankest are
really top-notch of books I mean things
like why nations fail which is a great
books out 600 pages I remember it took
me a few hours to read it it'll take you
15 minutes to get the same amount of
information because I don't remember
more than 15 minutes of information from
that book the same thing is true for
books like flow which is all about how
to make your life happier particularly
your work life they have books like
drive and Rich Dad Poor Dad all of these
things in 15 minute little packages they
are smart but they are not going to be
stiff they're not going to they're not
going to be abstruse all of them are
tailored just for you so that you are
getting all of the information in the
most entertaining possible way right now
blink as a special offer just for our
audience go to blink Escom slash Ben
right now today to start your free trial
or get three months off your yearly plan
when you join that's blinking bli n K
ist blink is calm slash Ben to start
your free trial and get three more you
can get three months off your yearly
plan I recommend getting the early plan
and getting the three months off you're
gonna want to keep it anyway
blink st.com slash Ben again use slash
Ben and that means that you are going to
be letting them know that we set you
plus you get that discount right you get
the the free trial or three months off
your yearly plan it's a great
informational resource and really
entertaining okay so
we begin with last night's national
championship game apparently the Georgia
Bulldogs lost the game in overtime to
the - to Alabama they - the Crimson Tide
and it was apparently a classic game but
I'm not gonna talk about the game
because I didn't watch him in into the
game what I did see was all of the
hubbub surrounding president from so
president Trump arrives at the game and
I think it's important to note something
for all the media coverage which is 95%
negative about President Trump probably
hatred of President Trump among
Democrats for this widespread sentiment
that President Trump is deeply unpopular
and no one likes him in places like
Alabama in places like Georgia Trump is
still a deeply popular figure and malice
in evidence last night at the Alabama
Georgia game or of course fans of both
teams were there and both of those
states are very red states so Trump
walks into the stadium and the way the
media covered this the press poll said
there was a mixture of cheers and boos
I don't see that what I heard and what I
saw from a number of different accounts
that were posted was there was almost
entirely cheers with a few scattered
boos mixed in here's what it looked like
when President Trump walked into the
stadium
Georgia and the University of Alabama
joined by our president Donald J Trump
okay so people were pretty enthusiastic
about Trump arriving it's a good move
for Trump to go to the national
championship game politically speaking
Barack Obama used to do this to every
sporting event he could find he went to
the baseball all-star game where he
threw out the first pitch like the girl
he he went to the I believe once the
n-c-double-a Championships at one point
or at least he used to go on ESPN every
year and talk about the NCAA
Championships used to appear before the
Super Bowl every year he was in front of
every camera he could find so for all
the people saying what is Trump doing in
the national championship game the
answer is that Obama did a lot of these
exact same things it's also against
Martin from to go considering that the
teams that were involved are going to
draw fans who are fans of his and it
wasn't just from showing up and walking
with ROTC it was also that he stood for
the national anthem so obviously this
has been a major controversy for a long
time in the United States whether they
should kneel or stand for the national
anthem
president Trump has stoked that
controversy for political gain for about
the last six months and presidents from
shows up and he stands for the national
anthem if you think that these imagistic
don't matter if you think the image
doesn't matter what Trump does that
you're sorely mistaken
people care much more about the
president signaling patriotism than they
do about the latest regulatory policy
it's one of the reasons Trump was
elected president one of the reasons
that Trump was elected is because people
perceive that Barack Obama was
uncomfortable with the trappings of
patriotism Obama was the kind of guy
who'd go abroad and talk about how all
countries had their patriotism he was a
guy who originally you recall was ripped
for not wearing a flag had enough until
he decided to reverse himself there
Trump for all the talk about you know
the problems with his perspective on
America and I've talked a lot about some
of the problems I think his perspective
on America holds Trump has a gut-level
patriotism or at least a gut-level
nationalism that resonates with people
him standing there for the national
anthem on the field with the members of
ROTC is smart politics and it plays with
a lot of his base here here's what it
looks like last night
[Applause]
and there was a that reminds me of
another image of Trump remember there
was an image where one of the members of
his of his honor guard at the helicopter
at the helicopter Air Force One I'm not
sure I can't run what they call it and
the guys hat blew off and you remember
that Trump went and grabbed the guys hat
and put the guy's hat back on his head
and there's a feeling that that Trump at
a root level likes the country and the
trumpeter root level doesn't feel scorn
for the country and that's the reason
for his popularity so Trump actually
stands there any sings along with the
national anthem now naturally the left
has to find a way to mock Trump so what
they do instead is they suggest he
doesn't know the words to the national
anthem this is all part and parcel of
their new pitch that Trump is not just
stupid he's actually crazy he doesn't
know the words to the national anthem
because he's mouthing along to the
national anthem Huffington Post made a
big deal out of this they suggested that
he didn't know the words and that he's a
fool of course here is video of Trump
singing the national anthem
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so this idea that and that Trump
doesn't know the words just silly
obviously he's singing the correct words
the reason that we showed a fair bit of
that clip is because one of the things
that's been happening is people are
taking this out of context and they are
and they're suggesting that he is
hearing the same music you are hearing
that's not the way that it works in
arenas like this he's hearing the echo
of the music right he's actually hearing
the music on the field and you the
audience are hearing the echo that is
played through the loudspeakers there's
a little bit of a delay I know this
because I've spoken enough big venues
that very often when you say something
what the audience hears is actually
being heard a second later and that's
what's happening here with Trump doesn't
matter the media is jumping on Trump
suggesting hitting other words to the
anthem that's absolutely asinine of
course from knows the words the national
anthem what I'm amazed by constantly is
the media's attempt to go out of their
way to paint Trump as stupid or crazy if
you're debating Trump is stupid or crazy
all you have to do is look at his
Twitter feed and then quoted a lot you
don't actually have to go to he doesn't
know the words of the national anthem or
he's suffering from early stage
Alzheimer's this is what they're now
arguing we're gonna talk in a second
about President Trump and the 25th
amendment but then this is this attempt
by the media to paint Trump as fully
crazy all it does is it makes people in
that stadium that people from Alabama
and Georgia think the media are out to
get from the reason being the media are
out to get Trump and do you think that
it's good for Trump were bad for Trump
when alabama's start running back beau
Scarborough no relation to Joe
Scarborough
is walking out to the field and very
much like Joe Scarborough starts
screaming f Trump at the top of his
lungs as he walks out onto the field
[Music]
right so you can hear it sort of there
he shouts F Trump in the middle of
walking out on the field while ESPN
cameras are rolling one thing that I
think Trump did quite brilliantly last
night apparently according to Clay
Travis Trump was was asked to interview
with ESPN on the sidelines and he turned
them down he told ESPN to stuff it
instead he did a local interview with in
with some local Georgia channel there's
some local Georgia radio channel and in
the interview with them instead of doing
the ESPN interview this is where trump's
populism or rightwell or trump's
populism orts is the feeling that he
cares about blue-collar people that he
cares about people who have been
traditionally ignored or or did or
degraded by the press from it does have
a connection to these folks he does he
has a feel of somebody who cares about
people like the people in that stadium
and that's going to benefit him and it's
one seat 20 election it's one of the
reasons why Democrats would be fools to
run anybody who has a white collar feel
as opposed to a blue-collar feel Joe
Biden would be a much better pick than
for example Kirsten Gillibrand Trump
still has a solid connection with a lot
of people who live in the Rust Belt as
well as in the south well in one second
I want to discuss with you the real
media push here which is that team Trump
is is hiding the fact that Trump is
legitimately crazy we're going to show
you the extent of the media bias because
it truly is astonishing and
demonstrative of just why Trump's base
is not going to desert him in 2020 but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over upside comm so when you
book business travel there's only one
way you should do it that's it upside
calm why because when you book at upside
calm you get the better business travel
experience they have concierge service
24/7 their team is hard at work to make
sure that your flight hotel rental car
all go off without a hitch they're
available on demand by chat phone and
email whenever you need them at they
monitor your business trip around the
clock they proactively keep you posted
on everything from the weather in the
city or change that you're going to to
changing your flight home so you can
adjust your meeting schedule it is just
the best level of service that you can
get plus when you book the room upside
calm you get a free pair of Bose
Soundlink wireless headphones which is
just awesome
so all you have to do for that is book
your first business trip with up side by
going to up side calm at /bin that's
upside calm slash pen and you can claim
your Bose that sound link wireless
headphones upside calm because you do
deserve a better business trip
the headphones are available while
supplies last you must be the it must be
your first offside purchase and there's
a $600 minimum purchase required but
pretty much any flight you take of any
length is gonna be 600 bucks anyway you
can see the site for complete details
upside calm the best level of service
you have ever experienced it's not gonna
be like the other travel sites where you
book your ticket and then they forget
about you and it turns out it's four
days later and you're still in Detroit
that's not gonna happen with upside comm
check it out
upside calm slash Ben it lets them know
that we sent you plus if you spend the
minimum amount then you get this this
free pair of Bose Soundlink wireless
headphones so make sure that you go and
check it out okay so the media
malpractice about from continues to to
push forward and as I say you see it in
things that are minor like the national
championship game and then you see it in
their coverage of the Michael Wolfe book
so Michael Wolf's book is still making a
lot of headlines the media simply will
not let it go they were in love with
Oprah yesterday but they're back to
Michael Wolf's book today Michael Wolfe
of course is this pseudo journalist who
basically tells anecdotal stories
without fact-checking them in any way
shape or form and he has this book fire
and fury which is no better than an Ed
Klein book you know ed Klein has written
all of these books about Hillary and
about Barack Obama mostly about Hillary
has been his sort of focal point and a
lot of people on the right will quote Ed
Klein or attempt to give credence to
rumors that Klein is passing around and
people on the Left say well he's not a
real journalist because he's not double
sourcing and then they'll go and they'll
pass around Michael Wolf's book they'll
pretend that Michael Wolf's book is well
substantiated that it's detailed that it
really contains the truth and you can
see from how the media is treating this
just how much they're lying about it so
I want to start here by showing you
Katie turns interview with Michael so
Katie tour of course over at NBC News
and Katy tur she demonstrates
full-fledged and so does wolf that the
media are engaged in complete and total
confirmation bias confirmation bias is
the is the phenomenon where you buy
information that already confirms the
feelings that you already had so you
didn't like Trump and say you're gonna
buy the story the Trump actually watches
the guerrilla Channel this is the thing
that happened last week there's a guy on
Twitter who called themselves himself
pixelated boat he's a parody accounts
and he tweeted out a fake portion of
Michael Wolf's book in which he
suggested that the White House staff had
been told by President Trump that he
wanted to watch guerrillas all day and
to the White House staff went and
produced a guerrilla channel which they
then had locally streamed into his TV
alone
Trump suggested that he didn't want to
watch the gorillas eating and mating he
only wanted to watch them fighting so
they cut out all the non fighting parts
oh it's just 24 hours a day of gorillas
fighting each other and Trump standing
next to the TV for 17 hours a day
watching the gorillas Channel and
yelling at the TV and urging the
gorillas to fight one another thinking
that he could control them so this fake
parody went out and a bunch of people on
the left thought it was real like people
on the left started tweeting out about
how Trump actually had constructed a
gorilla Channel it had something like
15,000 retweets people on the Left
thought that the gorilla Channel was a
real thing which I mean let's be real
there is only one gorilla Channel it's
in heaven and Harambee runs it but the
idea that this could pass around it can
only pass around really because there
are so many people who wanted it to be
true they wanted to believe that there
was a gorilla Channel the President
Trump had mandated and that he stood
that he sat scratching his head and
beating his chest and whooping to the
sounds of the gorillas fighting well
this is what the entire media are now
engaged in this this vast scale
confirmation bias so watch this
interview with Katy tour on NBC because
this is just a it is an exercise in
confirmation bias and how the media are
exacerbating it because that's not what
what sure I'm not I'm not in your
business I my evidence is the book read
the book if it makes sense to you if it
strikes the coif it rings true it is
true congratulations on the book and
congratulations and the president hating
it thank you appreciate your time sir
okay so a couple of things there that
are just insane first of all when he
says if it rings true it is true that is
the definition of bad journalism the
definition of bad journalism is if it
rings true it is true right and when
President Trump when he was then not
even candidate Trump was talking about
how Barack Obama was born in Kenya and a
lot of people said you know what that
rings true cuz Barack Obama kind of a
weird guy doesn't seem to hold a lot of
American principles if Trump it just
said if it rings true if it rings true
it is true you know what the media
would've said they would have said
alternative facts they said fake news
they'd have said that he's lying that
he's dissembling but Michael Wolfe goes
out there and says if it rings true it
is true that is not a journalistic
standard you've got to be kidding me if
it rings true it is true ok Michael
Wolfe is a joke and a pedophile does it
ring true I have no evidence that any of
that is real I'm a dad
he's not a really good journalist but I
have no evidence he's a pedophile but
this is ring true well what if I just
suggested that Michael Wolff likes to
kill puppies in his backyard I mean look
at the guy just look at his face
right does that ring true doesn't mean
it is true what if I suggested the
Michael wolf is actually Michael Myers
Mike Myers playing Michael wolf they
just shaved his head stuck on that pair
of glasses and now he's playing an extra
from Austin Powers does it ring true is
it true
again what stupidity and then for Katie
turn finish the interview by
congratulating him on from hating the
book if that doesn't demonstrate how the
media are a bunch of trolls I don't know
what does I mean that is just the
essence of troll Larry congratulations
on the president hating you because he's
such a bad guy if he hates you that's
really a compliment like if you're gonna
congratulate somebody on somebody hating
you then what you do is you congratulate
me on my mood Ahmadinejad hating me
right so like someone evil you want you
want to use that you say like Hitler hey
- congratulations yeah you don't think
Donald Trump hates you congratulations
on your book maybe he hates your books
full of crap maybe that's a possibility
and it turns out that the book largely
is full of crap and I'm not the only one
saying so but again this this media bias
is insane brian Stelter who's supposed
to be the sort of CNN Ombudsman hey
brian Stelter tweeted this out the other
day he's T tweeted out I stand corrected
I thought the RNC I've misquoted me but
the Pope came from it's CNN
International TV hit because the the GOP
had tweeted out an ad in which had
quoted the in which it quoted brian
Stelter is saying there were holes in
the book Stelter says I've deleted my
previous tweet about this big picture
point Wolf's errors are sloppy but many
Trump experts say the book rings true
overall my advice read it
skeptically rings true overall brian
Stelter is the is the supposed upholder
of truth
what does rings true nonsense like by
the way you don't have to go to Michael
Wolf's book to find stories that have
been confirmed by more than two sources
about President Trump acting crazy
sometimes right you can look at use your
eyes your eyeballs that are in your head
now you don't require Michael Wolf's
ridiculous anecdotes courtesy of Steve
Bannon I mean the whole book is
basically as told to Steve Bannon as
told by Steve Ben it's really silly so
brian Stelter gets hammered by Jake
Tapper this is one of the reasons why I
respect tapper as a journalist a lot of
the time so here is tapper yesterday
suggesting that this book is basically
just nonsense Wolf's reporting should be
met with skepticism the book is riddled
with errors and rumors and in his
marketing of the book wolf made the
unbelievable assertion that 100% of the
president's family members and top
advisers have concerns about his mental
fitness for the job 100% that's simply
not true and there's this three errors
in just this one paragraph on page 78
and the spelling of democratic
strategist Hillary Rosen's named Wilbur
Ross is identified as the labor
secretary when he's actually the
Commerce Secretary and wolf has reporter
mark Berman at a restaurant which Berman
says he's never been to okay so good for
tapper for going through this ringing
true is not truth this is why I have
more respect for tapper than I do for
the some of the other CNN journalists
speaking of bias at CNN CNN announced
today that Jim Acosta the grandstanding
ridiculous White House correspondent who
spends all of his time asking asinine
questions of the presidents of the
president spokespeople he's the guy who
tried to go after Stephen Miller
Wednesday on illegal immigration and
Miller basically just clocked him he's
the guy who goes after Sarah Huckabee
Sanders pretty much every day with his
ire and his fury he tries to do the the
old Dan Rather party tries to go in
there and act with with Umbridge and
indignation about everything Trump does
well now Jim Acosta has been elevated to
chief White House correspondent which is
just fantastic
well done CNN take the guy who's
obviously lobbying against the Trump
administration making me our chief White
House correspondent trying to turn him
into a star and then suggest there's no
media bias yeah sure and again you can
tell the media bias from exactly how
Michael Wolfe is pitching this right
Michael Wolf is pitching this is the
book that's gonna interrupts presidency
and the left is buying into that because
they want to see Trump's presidency end
they are interested in seeing Wolf's
book take down Trump they're suggesting
this is like a bomb went off in the
White House it's like a bomb went off in
the White House the book doesn't say
anything new except Steve ban and
mentally masturbating about how he
doesn't like Jerrod new vodka and how
Trump is and how Trump doesn't fulfill
his purposes is a grand national as
populist here's Michael Wolfe though
fulfilling all leftist fantasies that
this book is going to somehow results in
a 29th amendment there are not 29
members to the Constitution a 29th
amendment removal of the president due
to literary literary wounds right here
is Michael Wolfe going after Trump you
know I think one of the interesting
effects of the book so
far is a very clear emperor has no
clothes effect that the story that I've
told seems to present this presidency in
such a way that it says he can't do this
job the emperor has no clothes and
suddenly everywhere people are going oh
my god it's true he has no clothes okay
Nancy wolf is really excited about this
and that's the point wolf is really
excited about this and so he's left
they've been talking about the 25th
amendment so in a minute I'm gonna
explain you what the 25th amendment says
and why people who are talking about
removing from through the 25th amendment
process are totally crazy okay it's
never going to happen it's not a real
thing it's not a real thing but before I
talk about any of that first I want to
say thank you to our sponsor is over at
MVM t so do you see this magnificent
piece of time where do you see this
watch it is spectacular I wear every day
you can see it on the show here every
two actually have two MVM T watches my
wife has an MV MT wash my mother has an
MV MT watch and I have bought the vast
majority of those watches MVM T watches
are just fantastic they really are
top-notch they are clean they are sleek
they are professional they can take a
beating I mean my son as I've mentioned
before steals my watches and then likes
to hide them and or beat them against
the walls then this watch has been
ticking no problem it really holds up
under pressure and my son is about as
good a test as you're going to get for
watches under pressure
MVM T watches are really fantastic and
they're less expensive than their
equivalents in department stores because
they're cutting out the middleman
movement watches start at just 95 bucks
and an apartment started talking four to
five hundred bucks for watch like this
MVM t figured out by selling online they
can sell to you for a much better price
classic design quality construction
style minimalism check them out at MVM
t.com slash appear i've turned into a
watch junkie really since I since I
started using em VMT watches because
they have so many cool looks and in
really a wide variety of looks like my
watch is very did my dad has an MD MT
watch and it looks very different from
my watch
Clavin has an MV MT watch so does
Knowles they all look really different
and they're all really cool-looking they
have everything from kind of sporty
watches to sort more classic looking
watches and the MT comm slash up here
when you use slash Shapiro you get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns in case it turns out you don't
like it again my watch is
really clean design I really like this
one I have this one it's silver with the
blue face and I think it's really cool
looking and then I also have a black one
with the black face which is also a very
cool looking and the MT comm slash
Shapiro check it out
use that slash of Heroes that they know
that we say you couldn't speak more
highly of em DMT really really like the
people there as well so everybody has
been talking about Michael Wood from the
25th amendment
so Trump's crazy he's so crazy he's a
nut he's is incapable of fulfilling his
office his oath of office therefore we
have to call in the 25th amendment yeah
okay so let's go through briefly what's
exactly in the twenty-fifth amendments
you understand how insane this is the
suggestion that the 25th amendment is
gonna be used to oust President Trump it
would indeed be a coup you know people
have been used over using the term coup
when they say that there are leaks
inside the White House that that's a
coup or and they suggest that there's a
bad news story that's a coup no a coup
is when somebody is illegitimately
removed from office through nefarious
means okay to declare the President of
the United States crazy without an
actual diagnosis that he has severe
Alzheimer's or something is ridiculous
the 25th amendment was put in place
after the assassination of JFK because
people were worried what do you do if
the president's in a coma or something
and also with regard to Woodrow Wilson
because Woodrow Wilson was basically in
a coma for the last nine months of his
administration and his wife was
essentially president so I guess you
could have president Melania but people
didn't want to do that so they changed
the constitution so instead they went to
the 25th amendment here is what the 25th
amendment says it says whenever the vice
president and a majority of either the
principal officers of the executive
departments or of such other body as
Congress may by law provide transmit to
the president pro tempore of the Senate
and the Speaker of the House of
Representatives their written
declaration that the president is unable
to discharge the powers and duties of
his office
the vice president shall immediately
assume the powers and duties of the
office as acting president so basically
the VP in the cabinet have to go to the
Speaker of the House and the Senate
President pro tempore and they have to
tell him they have to tell those guys
fellas presidents out of it I'm taking
over so pens would have to go with the
rest of the cabinet do you think that's
going to happen of course that's not
going to happen but let's assume that it
did right let's assume that Mike Pence
suddenly got it in his head that he was
going to take Trump out for the 25th
amendment so what happens then that's
not the end of the story okay here's the
rest of the story there
laughter when the president transmits to
the president pro tempore of the Senate
and the Speaker of the House of
Representatives his written declaration
that no inability exists he shall resume
the powers and duties of his office
unless the VP and a majority of either
of the principal officers of the
executive department or of such other
body as Congress made by law provide
transmit within four days to the
president pro tempore of the Senate and
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives their written
declaration that the President does in
it is unable to discharge the powers and
duties of his office so Trump writes a
letter back and says I'm not crazy I'm
taking back the office he gets back the
office unless the VP and a majority of
the executive department so the VP in
the cabinet or the VP and some other
body set up by Congress go back to the
president pro tempore and Speaker of the
House and says no the president really
is crazy don't give him back the power
so what happens then now you have a
battle between the VP and the president
so thereupon Congress shall decide the
issue assembling within 48 hours for
that purpose if not in session if the
Congress within 21 days after the sheet
of the latter written declaration or if
Congress is not in session within 21
days after Congress is required to
assemble determines by two-thirds vote
of both houses that the president is
unable to discharge the powers and
duties of his office the VP shall
continue to discharge the same as the
Acting President otherwise the President
shall resume his duties okay so what are
they saying here they're saying that you
would have to have two-thirds of both
the House and the Senate a two-thirds of
both the House and the Senate okay that
is actually stricter than the
impeachment process
okay the impeachment process under the
Condor the Constitution of the United
States the federal the House of
Representatives passes by simple
majority the articles of impeachment
right that's what happened to Bill
Clinton Bill Clinton was impeached by
the house but then he has to be
convicted by I believe it's 2/3 of the
Senate in the United States right so
this idea that the that that the
twenty-fifth amendment is somehow an
end-around the impeachment process is
just crazy that's not exactly that's not
what happens right the process is I'm
just checking my work here that yes
that's right two-thirds of the members
present have to vote for conviction in
the Senate so under the 25th amendment
two-thirds of both houses have to vote
to get rid of Trump under the
impeachment process only two-thirds of
one house and a majority of the other
half devotes
get rid of Trump so everyone who's
talking about 25th amendment is totally
crazy it's not going to happen the only
way that it would ever happen is if
Trump were legitimately in a coma had a
heart attack or something
god forbid and then he were in a
long-term situation where he could not
actually discharge his duties right
that's legitimately the only way this
happened so for all those people who are
fantasizing about the 25th amendment try
reading the Constitution for a change it
may throw some cold water on your stupid
because it's really absurd it's really
absurd
okay so meanwhile speaking of really
absurd president Trump has been
successful in passing a lot of
Republican priorities in his first year
about looking forward to 2018 the polls
look pretty terrible for it Republicans
in 2018 if you look at the generic
congressional ballot the last time that
I checked the the generic commercial
billable check RealClearPolitics right
now the average on the generic
Congressional vote on Real Clear
Politics is deep plus 11 which is just
brutal now the gap has been closing a
little bit so both the economists YouGov
and Reuters Ipsos have it Democrats plus
6 Democrats plus 7 that's still a major
gap though right before that it was
Democrats plus 15 according Quinnipiac
and Democrats plus 18 according to CNN
so in any case it looks like Republicans
have some trouble one of the ways you
can tell that Republicans have some
trouble is a lot of the members of the
House have been stepping down in
districts that were won by Democrats so
Hillary Clinton one for example ed Royce
is District House Foreign Affairs
Committee Chairman Ed Royce from
California way I know representative
Royce I like representative Ross he
stepped down he said that he's not gonna
run for reelection so he stole he hasn't
stepped down formally he's not gonna run
for re-election which boosts the chances
Democrats win that seat if Royce were
running it would lean are according to
cook Political Report and now leans D so
he's the first of his California
colleagues to announce his retirement
the party was surprised by this
apparently according to the LA Times
they were surprised he's a 13 term
Congress person he published his
announcement on Twitter he said he
wanted to concentrate on his final year
as committee chairman right so that is
not good news for Republicans and again
if you look at those polls there they're
a bunch of Republican retirements the
list of Republican retirements
in the house for this term are is really
substantial right here here's a list of
Republicans who are currently talking
about retiring
after 2018 yeah this is it this is just
the list right now it's probably going
to get longer so the list includes let's
see represent Sam Johnson Republican of
Texas he's won in 1991 Ileana
ros-lehtinen of Florida John Duncan of
Tennessee they're the the list is Diane
black of Tennessee who says she's gonna
run for governor in Tennessee Jeff Flake
obviously in the Senate bob Corker in
the Senate Charlie 10 from Pennsylvania
announced that he is not going to be
running anymore jeb Hensarling the
Republican from Texas is not comparing
Dave bright Curt from Washington is not
gonna be running Dave Trott from
Michigan is not going to be running ted
poe from texas is not gonna be running
the frank Le'Veon doe from new jersey is
not going to be running jason chaffetz
from utah is not gonna be he resigned
already Tim Murphy from Pennsylvania Pat
- Barry from Ohio so Yee okay that's a
long list you're talking right there
about 13 House Republicans who have
resigned or will resign and you're
talking about two sitting Republican
senators who are already stepping down
though who are already stepping down
right and then if you look at the House
Republicans running for another for
another office so they leave their seat
vacant which mitt puts them up for grabs
at another five so already talking about
18 House Republicans who are leaving
their seats either just leaving them
absolutely or leaving them to run for
another office that does not spell
anything good for Republicans okay that
is not a good opening gambit for
Republicans in 2018 if they lose 23
seats they lose the House of
Representatives outright that may look
like a soft it may look a little bit
like a like a a weak prediction at this
point at this point you have to look at
toward toward Republicans losing 30 if
the day to hold any any sort of bearing
at all okay so and we're going to
continue in just a second with a big
announcement from the Arizona Senate
race I just suggested that Jeff Flake in
Arizona is not running for reelection
someone else doe wants to fill his seat
someone whose name you will know but
before we get to that first you're going
to have to subscribe so for $9.99 a
month you can get your subscription to
daily wire.com you get the rest of this
show live you get the recipe under
Clavin still alive the rest of Michael
moles is show live again to be part of
my mailbag on Fridays you're gonna get
discounts when the inevitable Shapiro
store finally arrives and if you get the
annual subscription then you get this
for $99 the greatest in all beverage
vessels is the annual subscription so
that means it's cheaper than the monthly
subscription you get all of those
aforementioned glories plus the leftist
years ha
or occult tumblr the greatest of all
beverage vessels plus it's time to get
your wheels turning in the keyboard is
humming because Tuesday January 16th
5:00 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific we're
doing our fifth episode of the
conversation that features the Daily
wires own Andrew Clavin and it's
moderated by Alicia Kraus if you
subscribe now you can be part of the
conversation you can ask a drew live
questions which she will answer for
everyone to hear Drew's conversation
streams live on The Daily wire Facebook
page and the daily wire YouTube channel
it's free for everybody to watch but
only subscribers can actually ask the
questions to ask questions as a
subscriber to log into our website at
daily wire.com you head over to the
conversation page and you can watch the
live stream and then you just start
typing into the daily water chat box and
the Alicia will funnel your questions to
Drew as they come in
for an entire hour again subscribe you
get your questions answered by Drew on
Tuesday January 16th at 5 p.m. Eastern 2
p.m. Pacific and join the conversation
ok if you also want to just check out
the show later and listen go over to
SoundCloud or iTunes Google Play
stitcher subscribe to our channel over
at YouTube and and please leave a
comment that always helps us we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so in other news it appears that the the
seats in Arizona that is now being
vacated by Jeff Flake has a few
contenders Kelly Ward obviously is
running she is um a somewhat kooky a
person I would say she's suggested that
chemtrails are poisoning the air okay
and says she's running and then you have
Joe Arpaio so Joe Arpaio announced today
that he's going to run for Senate which
is just spectacular he of course was
recently pardoned by a president Trump
his he had been sentenced for corruption
because he's basically using his office
apparently to target Hispanics this was
at least the allegation there are a lot
of people who suggested that that was
politically motivated but our Pyles
office in the past had targeted
publications in Arizona that reported on
his corruption in inside the Maricopa
County Sheriff's Office he gained
popularity among some immigration
hardliners and anti criminal hardliners
I remember the first time I heard a
sheriff Joe was was when there all those
stories about hoes wearing his in making
his inmates wear pink uniforms but he
was convicted and lost his elected
sheriff's office last year after more
than two decades now he says that he's a
big supporter of President Trump and has
a lot to offer Trump needs to stay out
of this race he'd be making a very large
mistake to endorse Sheriff Arpaio in the
same way that he endorsed for way more I
promise you there is more dirt on our
pile at least clearly beforehand and
there was even on more during the
primaries remember all of the child
molestation allegations about more drop
during the general not during the
primaries there's a lot of stuff on more
that made him unfit for office but
Arpaio has a lot of those same issues
our pilot says I'm gonna have to work
hard you don't take anything for granted
but I would not be doing this if I
thought I could not win I'm not here to
get my name in the paper I get that
every day anyway I mean to be fair he is
here to get his name a little bit in the
paper so Senator Kelly Ward is state
senator Kelly war she is running our
piyo is running representative martha
mcsalley is also expected to jump in
soon she's a more mainstream Republican
and if you're gonna support someone in
primary mcsalley seems like the best
available option because remember
Arizona is not a red state Arizona is a
purple state hey if you want to lose
another Senate seat and put the Senate
in jeopardy if you want to ensure that
if another justice steps down Trump is
not able to fill that seat with a good
justice then you can always make sure
that that seat goes Democrat remember
Republicans only have a fifty-one seat
majority right now
if they lose two more seats they are
toast in the Senate they and then you
have a fully Democratic Congress and
President Trump a dangerous prescription
for conservatives not just because
Democrats in Congress are extreme but
also because President Trump wants to
win and by win Trump means that he wants
to get things done not necessarily
conservative things but anything so
we've been lucky so far that he has
basically signed whatever it comes
across his desk he hasn't used his veto
pen at all so far as I'm aware it would
be questionable as to whether he would
actually use his veto pen if Democrats
started passing legislation or if you
would do what Bill Clinton did in his
second term and start working with
Republicans remember after Bill Clinton
lost his midterm election in 1994 he
started working with Republicans on
welfare reform than one reelection you
could see a similar move from the rights
and left by President Trump if Democrats
were to actually win control of Congress
right now the woman who's running on the
Democratic side is one name Kyrsten
Sinema
and she is the heavy favorite in the in
the Democratic primary she's also
relatively popular in state so
Republicans have to be very careful in
Arizona which means that mcsalley is
probably their best candidate there now
with all that said one of the major
issues that's going to occupy the Trump
administration in the very near future
is of course the issue of the deferred
action for childhood arrivals program so
to recapitulate what has happened so far
if you recall in 2016 President Obama
announced that he would be essentially
commuting the the dreamers I'm sorry
when was daca daca was not 2016 daca
took place in 2012
sorry was rose during the election cycle
of course Obama did it to pander to
Hispanic voters so Obama who signs in
executive amnesty that essentially
allowed everyone who arrived between
1981 and 2010 to stay in the country if
they came in as children and so they
would get to stay forever was the basic
idea here so that was illegal Obama
didn't have the authority to do that he
was essentially giving people legal
status without Congress approving of it
so Trump comes into office and he says
daca has now been revoked but he also
says I want to make sure that the
dreamers get to stay so Congress should
do something about this they should cut
some sort of a deal will make a grand
beautiful deal and if you don't make a
deal then maybe I'll just reinstate
tadka in March that was a very very
foolish negotiating stance I mean if you
are going to negotiate a salary with
somebody what you don't do
say listen boss I need $1,000 raise and
you know what's gonna happen if you
don't give me that thousand dollar raise
I'm gonna go right back to work
like just like it was before that's what
I'm gonna do so boom mic drop right
that's not exactly how you negotiate for
great negotiator Trump really has
botched the negotiation on daca so he
started off by essentially admitting
that he was not going to that he was not
going to let daca die daca was going to
survive no matter what and Democrats are
playing that for all they're worth
because right now Republicans are saying
Democrats let's make a deal right if you
want to akka reinstated we do too we
also want funding for the born wall we
want to end chain migration that's a
deal that I would make by the way if
there were a if there a deal to to for
border wall and ending chain migration
in exchange for reinsuring daca what I'd
be happy with that deal I would not I
would not be thrilled with that deal but
that is definitely a deal that you would
make because the reality is that the
vast majority of these dreamers are
gonna end up staying no matter what and
according to trump all of them are gonna
end up staying no matter what so you may
as well get the wall and get chain
migration and the chain migration is
much more of a danger to America's
immigration program than keeping people
who have already been here for 15 20
years I mean they've already been here
for 15 or 20 years in the country is
operating just fine in any case the
Democrats are refusing to allow that
sort of deal because they know that
they've got Trump over a barrel a little
bit here
Julian Castro the democratic
representative from Texas he comes out
and he says the Democrats will vote down
a border fix if it contains wall funding
thanks that Democrats should withhold
votes from a bill to help dreamers if it
includes funding for the wall I will
certainly vote against it and I know
most Democrats will vote against it I
can only speak for the House of
Representatives of course in the Senate
that's it they have different rules and
it's a different matter but I would
suspect that you will have the
overwhelming majority of Democrats vote
against it yes okay so if Democrats vote
that down that means it's gonna be hard
for Republicans to pass it because there
are a lot of Republicans who don't
actually want to pass anything that
enshrines daca in law so it'd be hard to
pass it in the house it would be
particularly hard to pass in the Senate
you lose one or two votes and you're
basically done you could certainly see
some of the hardliners in the Senate
making taking the stance that they're
not going to vote for any of these deals
now should they vote for beds you know
the answer is yes of course they should
if
Republicans I have a majority they
should just vote this thing through with
no Democratic support and then they'll
be seen as fixing daca and fixing the
illegal immigration system it'll be
interesting to see what a vote count
looks like what a whip count looks like
Pat Buchanan however who is the most
anti-immigration legal and illegal
advocate in maybe the United States he
suggested on the McLaughlin group which
I didn't even know still existed but he
he suggested on McLaughlin group that
Trump will indeed collapse on amnesty
and that daca will happen and there will
be no wall and there will be no end of
chain migration Pat will and should
President Trump agree to a darker deal
with Democrats well i my view is is no
but I do think this I think that Trump
will agree to the deal I don't think
you'll get the wall I think you'll get a
security fence on the border and other
things protections like that and I think
the pressure from the public elsewhere
on the daca thing because it is publicly
popular I think ultimately Trump will
concede on that and he's will be charged
with amnesty okay so you know I think
that Pappy Kenan is likely right he has
the air to the ground on these
immigration issues one of the things
that's worth noting is that at Trump's
break with Jeff Sessions his Attorney
General is not just about DOJ that break
actually has implications for
immigration because the reality is that
the the immigration plans that Trump
espoused during his run were very much
connected to Jeff Sessions immigrations
plans Jeff Sessions immigration plans
were very strict those were the ones
that were mirrored Stephen Miller was
Jeff Sessions chief of staff so that's
where all of this information was coming
from the fact that Trump in sessions are
nods is not good for those of us on the
right who would like to see illegal
immigration curbed even if we would like
to see some sort of process whereby
illegal immigrants are evaluated on a
one-by-one basis to see whether they are
benefits of the country or whether they
are not okay time for some things I like
and some things I hate and then we'll
deconstruct the culture briefly because
I have some more notes about the Golden
Globe so now we begin with some things I
like so I'm about to do something I've
never done before I'm gonna recommend a
movie with Chris Evans in it yes that's
right
there's a there's a movie out called
gifted I watched it on a plane the movie
is not amazing it is okay I think it's
gotten more plaudits than it than it
deserves the basic notion of the movie
is that Chris Evans is
essentially the uncle of a little girl
who is a genius genius in math her mom
was also a genius in math but the mom
committed suicide after solving a famous
equation and the moms mothers of his
little girl's grandmother was the one
who had been sort of steamrolling the
the daughter who committed suicide into
being in math and so the uncle
essentially took the kid away and
doesn't want her to to shine and so
that's that sort of the conflict of the
film that he wants her to live a regular
life but he also has taken her away from
a lot of the resources that would be
necessary for her to be the most
educated that she can be in terms of
math that's the central conflict of the
film here's a little bit of the of the
trailer please don't we go you can keep
homeschooling me tell you everything I
know no more argument okay we've
discussed this ad nauseam without
nauseam you don't know well it looks
like someone needs school who can tell
me what three plus three is everyone
knows it's six Vera can you stand up
please can you tell me what 57
multiplied by 135 this
okay whoo 7,000 695 the square root is
eighty seven point seven and change now
what does that nauseam mean the bill is
that the summit's well done it is it is
a well done film I will say that the the
part of Chris Evans that he plays in
this film is not like he's good in the
film he actually is I didn't know Chris
Evans could axe that was a surprise to
me I've never liked him in as Captain
America I thought he was awful in
Fantastic Four and that was my extent
they sent to my Chris Evans knowledge I
didn't think that he's like yeah he's
the greatest actor ever but he's pretty
he's decent in this film he just has a
sort of weird part to play where he's
supposed to be a college professor who
decides to go and like fix boats or
something which is such a Hollywood
conceit by the way there's not one
college professor in America who has
ever decided they're just gonna go scrub
boats down for a living like that that's
not a thing okay so other things that I
like so I have to show you this this was
going around the internet I've never
seen it apparently it's like nine years
old but it's just one of my favorite
things it is a local ad for a furniture
store in North Carolina called red house
and it is spectacular it is just so good
here here's the commercial can't we all
just get along at the red house
furniture we can I'm Richard aka big
head I worked at the red house and I'm
black I like puffing on the Papa
furniture into people's homes and I work
at the red house and I'm what I like
deer hunting bass fishing and extending
credit to all people at the reality
and I love to read house I'm white and I
love the Red House I'm a black woman and
I love the Red House I am white and the
Red House is for me that's pretty
spectacular stuff you can watch the
whole commercial but it's just it is it
is magic only in America that's it it's
a real American commercial and this is
the thing right the fact is that when it
comes to race relations most of us feel
like the red house right we're all who
cares like who cares but that's the
thing about the commercial that's really
funny is that you look at this you're
like this is this is how you act around
black friends if you're a white person
or hey I act around white friends if
you're a black person it's not that big
a deal and the fact that people make a
huge deal out of it is is an irritant
and that's why the commercial is so darn
funny it's really really funny okay
another news I do want to issue a hearty
congratulations to Jack Antonoff Jack
Antonoff of course is the fellow who is
dating Lena Dunham for five years and he
finally broke up with her which means
that either he awoke from his coma and
realized that he was in bed next to Lena
Dunham or it took him five years to chew
through his own arm and escape the
basement but congratulations to Jack
Antonoff for escaping a lifetime of that
Horror Show
yeah all I can think of when I think of
Jack Antonoff is that is that shot of
Tim Robbins at the end of Shawshank
Redemption with his hands up in the air
as the rain pours down on him after
crawling through a mile of stinking
sewage three football fields
Jack a good day for Jack Antonoff good
day for Jack as now okay time for one
quick thing that I hate and then I
wanted to construct culture for a second
so I did so here is the quick thing that
I hate so a quick thing that I hate
today comes courtesy of some Australian
show I guess where there's a guy named
genuine are you aware who this genuine
fellow is so I guess a genuine is some
sort of singer I guess that he is he is
famous for what song did he do okay
thank you
say louder because I missed it he didn't
ride my pony okay from genuine he's an
American singer songwriter and dancer
whenever I do a pop culture reference
like this I immediately
they have to check Wikipedia because I
have no idea who these people are but he
apparently did a show in Australia where
he was said where he's seated next to a
transgender woman meaning a man who says
that he is woman and this ridiculousness
ensued you know guys have chatted me up
not knowing my past but then as soon as
they find out whoa I'm a woman right I
care about any tease or anything in
front of it I'm just a woman okay so on
that score you would date me wouldn't
you
not if you told me you was no I'm not
telling you I'm trans I'm a woman okay
so he was getting all sorts of flack for
this because he wouldn't date a
transgender woman and then she asked for
and then he asked for a kiss right
there's a guy is that the guy asked for
a kiss and genuine says no oh how dare
he he's not he's saying trans women
aren't real women cuz they're not
because that person may indeed have the
junk downstairs like this this idea that
that you get to kiss whoever you want
pin and voiced your perspective like
first of all can we start with this
premise you don't have to kiss anyone
you don't want to in life how about that
let's just start from there right even
if this person were a real woman this is
not a printer a particularly attractive
woman from the stands normal standards
of some of them and feminine beauty if
genuine and does not want to be into
that genuine does not have to be into
that beyond that are we now suggesting
that a man is only a real man if he
kisses a man like that that is a genetic
man that is a biological man sitting
next to him suggesting that now genuine
is some sort of sexist for not kissing a
man that's weird
we had one of these instances earlier
nay if this becomes the new line and the
transgender rights movement good luck
with that one try it try selling people
on that one you want to gain support it
turns out the best way to gain support
for the transgender community is not
saying that we have to have sex with
transgender people like that it turns
out that is not a strong play not a
strong play okay quick deconstruction of
the culture so a couple of things worth
noting about the Golden Globes that have
not really been noted enough so far
number one okay this comes courtesy of
it the New York Post for all of the talk
about me too and times up and now we're
standing up against sexual harassment
abuse in Hollywood
okay here is the problem Rose McGowan in
Asia Argento accused Harvey Weinstein of
rape
were invited to the Golden Globes
Argento tweeted I can only speak for
myself but not only was I not invited to
the Golden Globes nobody asked my
opinion about times up or to sign the
letter McGowan said now one of these
fancy people wearing black to honor our
rapes would have lifted a finger had it
not been so I have no time for Hollywood
fakery rosanna arquette who accused
weinstein of sexual misconduct tweeted
to a follower no we weren't invited
Annabella cro
daryl hannah mira sorvino none of us
were Patricia Arquette replied that's
not cool all of you should have been
included I wasn't asked either but who
cares it's great they're doing it and we
will too well no actually it's not great
that they're that they're a bunch of
hypocrites who won't even invite the
victims it just shows you that all of
this is for show and speaking of for
show all these people virtru signalling
after doing pretty much nothing on
politics for their entire careers but
they have to show how wonderful they are
so all of these women decided they were
gonna bring female activists to the
Golden Globes as their as their partners
so Rosa Clemente joins Susan Sarandon
who is Rosa Clemente she's an activist
an independent journalist focusing on
issues affecting the black and Latino
community she's the president of know
thyself Productions which centers around
hip-hop activism and immigrants rights
yeah that's not virtuous signaling to
bring that lady to take the golden
globes and then like the only way you
hear about this is because there's a
piece at Huffington Post I mean you want
to talk about tokenism this is the
essence of tokenism and then you have
Meryl Streep who brought along a shampoo
who is an advocate for domestic workers
and those involved in family care yeah
I'm sure that that's high on Meryl
Streep's priority list I mean because
this is the first I've heard of it my
favorite personally was Sarah Jaya
Rahman who attended the Golden Globes is
he guest of Amy Poehler she is best
known for organizing low-wage restaurant
workers in fighting for fair pay how
about any Poehler sells her jewelry and
gives it to the restaurant workers for a
fair pay right Emma Stone Berlin Billie
Jean King's lesbianism at Wimbledon is a
major issue in today's America it's
something that we definitely have to
press for all of the virtue signaling is
just a high-level it just generates a
high level of irritation as well it
should it's really silly and the idea
that this is making any sort of
difference other than the alienating
people is really dumb okay so we will be
back here tomorrow with all of the
latest news i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike or Mina hair and makeup is by Jo
opera the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford Publishing 2017